when you first become a junior developer
your code will look like play-doh snakes
but as you progress to senior developer
and learn about software design patterns
your code will look like the sistine
chapel but when you then progress to
principal engineer you'll realize that
nobody wants to maintain the sistine
chapel for a silly website and go back
to making play-doh snakes in today's
video you'll learn about 10 different
software design patterns along with the
pros and cons of using them which can be
very subjective and controversial one of
the most influential books in the
history of programming is design
patterns by four c plus plus engineers
called the gang of four it breaks down
23 different approaches to address
recurring problems that programmers face
which are categorized as creational
patterns how objects are created
structural patterns how objects relate
to each other and behavioral patterns
how objects communicate with each other
becoming a proficient software engineer
is not about memorizing the syntax of a
programming language but rather the
ability to solve problems with it by the
end of this video you'll understand a
variety of different patterns for
solving problems as they relate to
modern app developers before we get
started i want to give a big shout out
to refactoring.guru they gave me
permission to use some of their graphics
that explain design patterns better than
anything else out there they're based in
ukraine and it's seriously one of the
coolest programming websites on the
internet design patterns are really
interesting because they're not just
like algorithms that you can copy and
paste from stack overflow you actually
need to use your brain to implement them
it can be tempting to implement them all
over the place but when used improperly
they can add additional complexity and
boilerplate to a codebase the book is
not the bible and there are many
criticisms of it regardless knowing how
to recognize design patterns will help
you level up as a programmer the first
pattern we'll look at is singleton which
is very easy to understand it's a type
of object that can only be instantiated
once in typescript we might implement a
singleton class called settings to
represent the global app settings data
we'll give it a static instance property
and then make its constructor private so
that it cannot be instantiated with a
new keyword we then create a static git
instance method that will check to see
if the instance has already been created
and if not it will create a new one and
that ensures that only one object can be
created that's great and all but here's
where things become a little more
nuanced in javascript we have object
literals and also the concept of global
data and objects are passed around by
reference we get all the same basic
characteristics as this pattern by
simply creating a global object the
pattern itself is really just extra
boilerplate that we don't need it's an
entirely different story in c plus plus
but the moral is to lean on your
language's built-in features before
implementing a fancy design pattern now
let's take a look at the prototype
pattern which is just a fancy word for
clone if you've done object-oriented
programming you should be familiar with
inheritance where a class can be
extended with a subclass one problem
with inheritance is that it can lead to
a complex hierarchy of code the
prototype pattern is an alternative way
to implement inheritance but instead of
inheriting functionality from a class it
comes from an object that's already been
created this creates a flat prototype
chain that makes it much easier to share
functionality between objects especially
in a dynamic language like javascript
which supports prototypal inheritance
out of the box imagine we have an object
named zombie this is our prototype but
now we want to create a new object based
on it that also has a name we can do
that with object create by passing the
zombie as the prototype then specify
additional properties like name for the
new object the interesting thing is that
if you log this object you'll only see
the name and not the eat brains method
however if you try to call that method
it will still work that's because
javascript will go up the prototype
chain until it reaches the root looking
for any methods or properties on the
parent objects you can always get the
prototype from an object by using this
proto property however that's not a
modern best practice and instead you
should use object get prototype of now
when it comes to classes in javascript
prototype refers to its constructor and
that means that we can extend a class
with additional functions if we want to
however that's also generally considered
a bad practice now let's switch gears to
the builder pattern imagine you're
running a hot dog stand and when a
customer places an order they need to
tell you everything they want in the
sandwich in the constructor that works
but it's kind of hard to keep track of
all these options and we might want to
defer each step to a later point with
the builder pattern we create the object
step by step using methods rather than
the constructor and we could even
delegate the building logic to an
entirely different class in javascript
we'll have each method return this which
is a reference to the object instance
that allows us to implement method
chaining where we instantiate an object
then chain methods to it but always get
the object as the return value you'll
come across this pattern frequently with
libraries like jquery but it's gone a
bit out of style in recent years another
pattern you may come across is factory
instead of using the new keyword to
instantiate an object you use a function
or method to do it for you that may
sound trivial but here's a practical
example let's imagine we're building a
cross-platform app that runs on both ios
and android they both have the same
interface but in our code we're doing a
bunch of conditional checking to
determine which button to show that's
not very maintainable instead we can
create a subclass or function that will
determine which object to instantiate
now instead of repeating the same logic
we use the factory to determine which
button should be rendered now we're
ready to look at the first structural
pattern facade a facade is the face of a
building inside that building there's
all kinds of shenanigans corruption and
complexity that the end user doesn't
need to know about a facade is basically
just a simplified api to hide other
low-level details in your code base
let's imagine we have classes for the
plumbing system and electrical system
and inside of them we have all kinds of
complex stuff going on like pressure and
voltage the people living in the house
don't need access to these low-level
details so we create a facade class that
contains the low-level systems as
dependencies but then simplifies their
operation like we might combine all the
electrical and plumbing details into a
single method so the end user can simply
turn them on or off with a single method
almost every package that you install
with javascript could be considered a
facade in some way like jquery is a
great example of a facade for the more
annoying low-level javascript features
the next structural pattern we'll look
at is proxy which is just a fancy word
for a substitute like in school you
might have a substitute teacher to
replace the real thing in programming
you can replace a target object with a
proxy but why would you ever want to do
that well a great case study is the
reactivity system in vue.js in vue you
create data but the framework itself
needs a way to intercept that data and
update the ui whenever that data changes
the way view handles that is by
replacing the original object with a
proxy a proxy takes the original object
as the first argument then a handler as
the second argument inside of which we
can override methods like get and set
which allows us to run code whenever a
property is accessed on the object or
changed for example inside of set we
might tell the framework to re-render
then use reflect to update the data on
the original object the end user can now
work with a proxy just like the original
object but it can trigger these side
effects behind the scenes proxies are
also commonly used when you have a very
large object that would be expensive to
duplicate in memory and now we're ready
to look at some behavioral patterns
starting with iterator the iterator
pattern allows you to traverse through a
collection of objects modern languages
already provide abstractions for the
iterator pattern like the for loop when
you loop over an array of items you're
using the iterator pattern but one thing
that really chaps my ass about
javascript is that there's no built-in
range function what i wish i could do is
easily iterate 10 times at a certain
interval we can actually do that fairly
easily by implementing our own iterator
pattern in javascript you can do that by
defining an object that has a next
method on it that function needs to
return an object that has a value which
would be the current value in the loop
and a done property so it knows when to
finish iterating in this case we will
keep moving on to the next step if the
start value is less than the n value but
for each iteration we will increment the
start value with a step eventually the
start will be greater than the end at
which point we can return an object with
the done property as true and that tells
javascript to stop iterating now a cool
technique here is that we can add symbol
iterator to this object which allows us
to use it in a regular for of loop at
the end of the day with iteration you
start with a collection and then write
some code that determines how to get
from the beginning to the end it's a
pull based system unlike the next
pattern we'll look at observer which is
a push-based system the observer pattern
allows many objects to subscribe to
events that are broadcast by another
object it's a one-to-many relationship
in the real world you might have a radio
tower that sends out a signal then a
bunch of receivers who listen in at the
same time this pattern is used all over
the place in app development like in
firebase when your data changes on the
server all your client apps are
subscribed to it and automatically
updated with the latest data in our code
here i'm going to bring in the rxjs
library to simplify the demonstration of
this pattern it provides a subject class
which is the data that we want to listen
to now once we have a subject we can add
multiple subscriptions to it the subject
will keep track of all these
subscriptions and call their callback
functions whenever the data changes
experiment with this pattern right now
by clicking like and subscribe on this
video now at some later points we can
call the next method to push a new value
to the subject whenever that happens
every subscription will be notified
personally i like to think of this as a
loop that unfolds over the dimension of
time but now let's move on to the
mediator pattern a mediator is like a
middleman or broker imagine we have a
class for airplane and runway we might
have multiple runways and multiple
airplanes and somehow we need to figure
out if an airplane is clear to land on a
given runway currently to do that all
these objects would have to communicate
with each other we have a many-to-many
relationship that's very dangerous both
in real life and in programming a
solution is to create a mediator like an
air traffic controller that sits between
the runways and the airplanes to provide
coordination and communication here's a
more practical example in the express.js
web framework there is a middleware
system you have incoming requests and
outgoing responses middleware sits in
the middle by intercepting every request
like an airplane and transforms it into
the proper format for the response the
runway it provides a separation of
concerns and eliminates code duplication
and that brings us to our tenth and
final design pattern state where an
object behaves differently based on a
finite number of states in your code
you've likely used conditional logic or
switch statements to handle a bunch of
different possibilities based on the
state or data in your application code
like this generally doesn't scale very
well the state pattern allows you to
start with one base class then provide
it with different functionality based on
its internal state the idea is related
to finite state machines and libraries
like xstate where the goal is to make an
object's behavior predictable based on
its underlying state in this example we
have a human class that will think
something different based on its mood
currently we're doing that with a switch
statement but another way to go about it
would be to create a separate class for
each possible state inside each class we
will have an identical method that
behaves differently now in the human
class we set the state as a property and
whenever that method is called we
delegate it to its current state that
means whenever the state changes the
object will behave in a completely
different way but at the same time we
don't have to change the api or use a
bunch of conditional logic i'm going to
keep things simple and wrap it up there
but remember there are a bunch of other
design patterns out there to learn
become a pro member at fireship io to
learn how to apply patterns like this in
real applications thanks for watching
and i will see you in the next one